[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
174 of the weekly "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast."
I'm Aja Hammerly, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Aja.
How are you doing?
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm pretty
good, actually-- excited
about this week's episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I've been
up since 5:00 AM Eastern.
[ROOSTER CROWING]
And now I'm in San Francisco.
So I don't know what day
it is, but it's great.
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm
so sorry, Mark.
But I'm glad that you're
out in the community
teaching folks awesome
stuff about Agones.
MARK MANDEL: I do stuff.
It's cool.
So this week, we have
some pretty cool people
coming to hang out with us.
We have Ann Wallace, security
practice lead, and Michael
Wallman, TPM of
Cloud migrations,
both from the Professional
Services Organization, or PSO.
So they're going to talk
to us all about what
the PSO team does
here at Google Cloud
and how they help out customers.
AJA HAMMERLY: And later,
we've got a question
of the week about Cloud Build.
But first, let's do the
cool thing of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: We have
many cool things.
What have you got, Aja?
AJA HAMMERLY: One
of our co-workers,
Amy Unruh, built
an app that uses
Cloud Vision to identify
key features of images
that are texted to it.
The link is going to
be in the show notes.
And if you have lots of pictures
of cats or pretty plants,
it will tell you all about them.
And its confidence in
its identifying them.
It's a really cool
example of how
you can hook up
some of our ML APIs
to your existing applications.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So as many people know,
I really love games.
[CHIMING]
So this isn't
specifically Cloud.
But it was so awesome,
I just thought
I'd mention it-- on the "Google
Blog," called "Want to Change
the Game?
Design your own
with Google Play."
So that Change the Game
program came out of Google Play
last year, teamed up
with [? Cosmic ?] Games.
They're looking for teens that
want to share their game idea
and vision of the
future of gaming,
basically for a chance
to see their game come
to life on Google Play.
The grand prize winner
of the challenge
will win $15,000 towards a
college scholarship and $15,000
for their school or community
center's technology program,
which is really awesome.
There's a whole bunch of
other stuff in there as well.
Unfortunately, it is
US residents only.
But if you want to
get involved or you
know a teen that might
want to get involved,
I will have a link in
the show notes to apply.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
sounds awesome.
My other cool
thing for this week
is if you saw the
developer keynote
at Next, either in person or
you watched all the recordings
through the live stream,
the "Game of Life"
app that was demoed
during that keynote
is still up if you
want to play with it.
And it's at gameoflife.dev.
MARK MANDEL: How fun.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
It's really cool.
I didn't ever think of "Game
of Life" as a team sport.
I always thought of it as a
fun, mathematical exercise.
But it's actually
a lot of fun when
there's five teams
playing, trying
to out-glider each other.
So if folks want to check
it out, it's still up there.
Feel free to go try it, and
compete against your coworkers.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Last but not least,
again, I seem
to be picking
semi-non-Cloud stuff.
This is a Google Search thing.
But it was just too
adorable to pass up.
I'm going to read
the first paragraph
because it's fantastic.
"It's not quite Caturday,
and we're a few months away
from the dog days of summer.
But searches for
pets never paws.
Around the world, people
constantly ask Google questions
about their furry friends.
So there's no time
like the present
for a good old-fashioned,
'oh, my god, look
at that little' face-off."
So it's basically an article
talking about how people
search for about dogs and cats.
And not only is an
article discussing it,
they made a website called
whydocatsanddogs.com,
talking about all the trends
that people ask about.
Why do dogs do certain things?
Or why do cats do certain
things, such as licking,
or eating, or moving
around, or shakes,
or just weird sounds
that they make?
My dog makes little
weird sounds.
So it's a lot of
fun, whether you're
a cat person or a dog person.
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm super
excited about that
because we all know
you're a dog person.
But I am definitely
a cat person.
And I'm sitting
here recording being
supervised by one of my cats.
[MEOWING]
MARK MANDEL: And my dog is fast
asleep next to me, snoring.
[SNORING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Dogs are
so much better behaved.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Sometimes.
Why don't we go have a
chat with Ann and Michael,
though, and get the
interview going?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this week, I am very excited
to have two wonderful people
come and join us.
We have Ann Wallace,
security practice lead,
and Michael Wallman,
TPM of Cloud migrations
joining us from the
professional-- the services
department for Google Cloud.
How are you both doing today?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: I'm good.
ANN WALLACE: I'm doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us and coming
to talk to us all about
professional services
and what it does.
Before we do that,
do you want to tell
us a little bit about yourselves
and what you do here at Google?
ANN WALLACE: Sure.
My name's Ann Wallace.
I'm based in the
Portland office.
I am currently the
global security practice
lead for Google PSO, or
Professional Services.
The security practice
is fairly new.
We spun off of the
infrastructure practice
about six months ago.
So I've been helping build
that out within the Americas
and globally.
Prior to Google I spent 14 years
at a major athletic company
in Portland.
I had wide roles in
architecture and engineering.
And when I'm not
working, you can
find me running
very long distances
on trails and in the mountains.
MARK MANDEL: You run, like,
ridiculously long distances.
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
50Ks, 50 miles.
My dog has run up
to 30 miles with me.
MARK MANDEL: My dog barely runs.
ANN WALLACE: [LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Like if
we hit a hill, she's like, uh,
it's hard-- and no.
[DOG WHINING]
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
I have a German
short-haired pointer.
They are very energetic dogs.
MARK MANDEL: Michael,
you want to tell us
a little bit about yourself?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Sure.
I run double
ultra-marathons because I
have a rambunctious 3-year-old,
long, curly blond hair, who
we call "the dude."
So I'm constantly
chasing after him.
Occasionally, I'll chase after
mountain lions in the Berkeley
Hills.
For professional services,
I'm an infrastructure practice
lead.
And you know
infrastructure is kind
of the catch-all practice--
compute, storage, networking,
containers, appdev, security.
But we're beginning to spin
off these subpractices,
and that's where Ann came
in and picked up security.
So outside of that, I
do big gnarly migrations
from on-prem to Cloud, from
other clouds to other clouds.
And yeah, I'm cloudy.
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
And actually, Michael and I met,
it was probably six years ago,
outside of Google.
The company I was
working for, he
helped us do our
first Cloud migration.
So then we just ended
up at Google together.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yes.
And I remember debugging a
custom Perl configuration
management system.
It was amazing.
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
So luckily, we don't
have to do that anymore.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yeah.
AJA HAMMERLY: So y'all
said that you work for PSO.
What does PSO do?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: We help
customers migrate applications
and storage around.
We help them, in essence,
move generally from on-prem
to Cloud.
Right?
That's like our charter.
More recently, it's
been moving customers
from clouds to other
clouds and setting up
these hybrid environments.
And you can imagine the
challenges with this.
I think customers
that are kind of maybe
sitting in the San Francisco Bay
Area that are more tech heavy
have an easier job.
But we have to
service all customers.
Therefore, we can fly
out to the Midwest
and service some
customers there.
And it's different challenges.
So--
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
I think, in a nutshell,
that's what we do.
But I think there's a little
bit more to that as well.
We work a lot.
You can think of us as
postsale versus the presales
where you have our customer
engineers and solution
architects.
But we also partner very heavily
with those teams and work
on solutions around
security, data migration, AI,
ML sort of things.
And we also are gaining
a lot of customers
who are wanting to figure
out how to move their VM
applications to containers.
So it's not just the
traditional lift-and-shift kind
of scenarios anymore.
Also, I speak at several
conferences a year.
And we're at Google
Next, the Cloud summit.
And we work pretty
closely with a lot of PMs.
I work very closely with
a lot of the security PMs.
We have a lot of input
into the roadmaps
for a lot of the
services, GCP services,
just because of customer input.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: To add to
that, everything kind of starts
with the customer.
Right?
So the Professional Service
Org. is the one that
touches the customer the most.
We're there.
We're friends with the customer.
I have dinner with the
customer, and then I
help them design their
next-generation products.
MARK MANDEL: So what
does a typical engagement
with a customer
actually look like?
Where do they go?
How does it get started?
And then where does
it go from there?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: It
starts with a scoping.
Right?
It starts with a dream--
[ANGELIC CHORUS]
--specifically a GCP.
It starts with a dream of, like,
I want to operate like Google.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: And
it just starts there.
And then you kind
of work backwards.
And what does that mean?
It means being flexible, fast
deployments, able to iterate
very quickly, being secure.
So it starts there.
And then we kind of work
backwards and figure
out, how do we actually
make it a reality?
And so it's challenging.
Right?
Because customers are running
more monolithic applications.
So they're older, and now they
want to run in containers,
and microservices, and how
to get the data up there,
et cetera, et cetera.
ANN WALLACE: But I
wouldn't say there's really
a typical type of engagement
because every customer is
so unique and brings
different challenges to us.
And it's not always technical.
Sometimes it's more
organizational.
But we have to navigate through.
But sometimes, the
conversations start with us.
Sometimes they start
before us, again working
with maybe solution architecture
team or customer engineers.
And then we get pulled in when
they want a little bit more
than those teams can provide.
And it might just start
with a conversation.
Maybe you're at a conference,
and meet up with somebody,
and say, hey, yeah, we
have these sort of things.
I still feel like
it's pretty organic
how a lot of these
engagements start.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Also
with the packages,
I mean, Ann, I think
you're 100% correct.
We're constantly trying to
generate reusable content,
like these reusable packages.
But we found it hard in the
sense of that every customer's
unique.
It's amazing.
They're using different
flavors of code,
and different flavors of
OSs, and different networks.
So I've been in
Cloud a long time.
And there are common
patterns, but it's amazing
how many different
combinations you see.
MARK MANDEL: And when
you're doing an engagement,
what sort of hands-on
engagement are you having there?
I mean, are you sitting
down and building out
architecture diagrams?
Are you sitting next to
engineers and writing code?
Or--
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
I think it's a little
bit of everything.
And sometimes the
engagements are short.
So with security, we have
just a security workshop.
So we'll go in to a customer
for around three days
and do a lot of security
deep-dives into our services,
a lot of best practices kind
of tutorials, whiteboarding.
Then we have customers who
want more of the, come in.
Tell us how to move this
from the data center VMs
to containers in GCP.
And that might be coming up with
a technical design document.
So it's writing out a lot of
use cases and diagramming that.
But then there also
might be that case where
it's like, hey, this is great.
You've diagrammed
all this for us
and delivered this
technical design document.
But we really need
help implementing that.
So then we might have another
engagement where we do that.
We also leverage partners to
help with some of this work.
So if there's a lot
of hands-on keyboard
or they want more
staff on, we tend to,
instead of having Googlers set
a company for months on end,
we use partners to do that.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yeah.
I would say absolutely.
I mean, Google has
never traditionally
been a consulting company.
You don't think of Google
as a consulting company.
So we're definitely
partner-heavy.
But we do try to mimic
some of the success Google
has had internally at
our larger projects.
So for example, we have
a TPM that maps to a TL
that maps to partner engineers.
And we try to run--
MARK MANDEL: Can you
explain those acronyms just
for those who aren't Googlers?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Oh, sure.
Technical Program Manager,
TL is the Technical Lead.
That's how we develop
our products internally.
And so we've had
a lot of success
mimicking that model at some
of our larger customers.
And then we're able
to iterate faster.
Everything is documented.
And we're status reporting well.
And another added layer
of complexity that we see
is that we're not just GCP.
Right?
We're G Suite.
We're Chrome.
We're Android.
So that adds just
another layer of--
I wouldn't say complexity.
But when they go
all in on Google,
it's like they get access to
all these different things.
And it's kind of interesting
how you can really
transform a business, not
just from a technical stack
but from a people's in-process.
So that's something new that
we've been working on as well.
AJA HAMMERLY: So you guys
are on the front lines.
You're hanging out
with customers.
You're learning things.
You're helping folks.
Any trends or
changes that you're
seeing that you find
particularly interesting?
ANN WALLACE: One
of the trends we're
seeing a lot is multicloud.
So you have customers who
have been in AWS or Azure
for a while.
But then they see
things that we're
doing that maybe the other
cloud providers aren't doing,
that we're just
doing it differently.
So we're seeing customers
coming to us through GKE.
Or we see customers coming to
us for all our ML technologies.
But then maybe they continue to
use the other cloud providers
for other things.
And I also, I think,
really in the last year,
it's been a big uptick
in GKE or Kubernetes.
A lot of companies now,
it's like, if we're
moving to the cloud, we just
want to move to containers.
We don't want to deal
with VMs anymore.
MICHAEL WALLMAN:
Again, I can concur,
being an old-school BSD person.
And as an infrastructure lead,
infrastructure historically
is compute network storage.
And now they're beginning
to abstract all that away
into this open-source cloud.
I mean, that's what
[INAUDIBLE] says.
We're the open-source cloud.
And therefore, we're
moving away from VMs
and this type of thing.
And we're going to containers,
GKE, Istio, service meshes.
And so the long-term
vision, I believe, of GCP
is to be the open-source cloud.
You can run your compute here.
You can move it on-prem.
You can move data around.
So there's a lot more, I guess,
a momentum to that direction.
Companies want to get there
because they kind of don't want
to be tied to a cloud provider.
They want their freedom.
And I believe GCP is
moving that direction.
We're trying to just open it up.
If you want to use GCP, great.
You want to run
on-prem, go right ahead.
That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Are you seeing
any particular GCP products
that are super hot right now?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: CSP, and I wish
I knew what the acronym meant.
ANN WALLACE: Cloud Services
Platform, that's what it is.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: This
is a-- and ironically,
Eric Brewer, an old
professor of mine,
is kind of leading
the charge here.
It's just the open-source cloud.
It's containers, Istio.
And now we're extending
it out in that
you can extend kind of like
the Kubernetes language
that's in YAML
deployment language.
And now you can extend it
out to further GCP services.
So now I can start defining
Pub/Sub topics and Cloud SQL
databases all within this
Kubernetes construct.
So I'm super excited to
see that happen and-- yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Ann,
you seeing anything
in particular with
your customers?
ANN WALLACE: I think
what I'm seeing
is it's not so much hot
services because I've
been talking to customers who
are really wanting security
first.
I think the trend is
really to get the security
teams at the table
from the beginning.
I think a year ago,
even six months ago,
we'd have customers who
plan all these deployments
and were ready to
go to production.
And then, all of a sudden,
they get a big red flag.
They're like, no.
Because the security
teams aren't
brought in from the beginning.
So I'm really seeing a
passion from customers
about getting the security
folks to the table first.
And coming from a
security background,
I'm very happy to
see this, and just
making security part of
the deployment pipeline,
baking security in from the
beginning so they don't have
to think about it later on.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Absolutely.
I would say one more thing I'm
seeing a lot is very large data
migrations.
And I'm not talking about 10
terabytes or even 10 petabytes.
I'm talking a
hundred-plus petabytes.
And so the new challenges
for the infrastructure team
is, how do I even
move this data around?
Right?
I know there are some products
that you come in, and plug
a fiber in, and you're
supposed to close your eyes
and pray that all
the data gets copied.
But it's just much
more than that
because you're applying
security policies to the data.
You're encrypting it.
And this amount
of data, I think I
did an analogy in a
presentation saying,
we're moving so much data
at some of our customers,
if you were to stack
the hard drives up,
it would be higher than
like three Golden Gate
bridges or something.
It's massive amounts of data.
And I think this is
fairly new that I
haven't experienced to date.
MARK MANDEL: Why
are they doing that?
MICHAEL WALLMAN:
Servers go end-of-life.
They're running these gigantic
Hadoop clusters, NetApp filers.
They just go end-of-life.
And then now they're faced with,
how do I make use of this data?
I need to obviously run
MapReduce or parallel
process it.
And so I think it's a
combination of end-of-life
and the new frontier of AI.
They want to tap into
Google's AI for the data.
And the only way to
do that, obviously,
is to have the data in Cloud.
But again, it's
totally new challenges.
I mean, you don't just
rsync or FTP the data up.
You know?
MARK MANDEL: Given that you
work so much with customers,
you mentioned previously
that you work a lot
with product managers as well.
Is that sort of shaping
product and providing feedback?
What does that internal
stuff look like?
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
So there is a lot of that.
So I work closely with a
lot of the security PMs,
so Andy Cheng, CJ Johnson, Maya.
So it is giving feedback.
I've also been
contributing to some
of the PCI work and
compliance work we're doing.
And we also do sessions at
Next, the Cloud summits.
We weed internal and what
we call SME academies,
so it's leveling up a lot of
the folks that are in the field,
so PSO, the customer
engineers, solution
architects on security.
So we do this a couple
of times a year,
bring a lot of the security
PMs and other folks
to talk about roadmaps,
what's going on in the field,
so we're all kind
of on the same page.
And I've been helping build
out some demos for the products
that we have.
So again, that's
partnering with Andy a lot.
So yeah, there's a lot of
exciting things going on.
But I really love
the fact that we're
able to feed back
into the products
and give input into
what's being built.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: I would say I
have a love-hate relationship
with product managers.
[LAUGHTER]
Let me explain.
We mostly love each other.
But back to this.
When you're migrating
200 petabytes
to a storage platform, there's
a lot of things to consider.
And so what we do is--
as a TPM, I'm basically
negotiating between product
management and the customer.
Right?
And it's this constant
on in negotiation.
And we drive product.
Like for example, the
dual-bucket GCS feature,
that I believe now is in beta,
came from a customer saying,
OK, I'm going to have my
100 petabytes in us-east-1.
And if I have a regional outage,
and I have a security event,
and, I mean, to go
through this data,
like what am I supposed to do?
So there's this new
dual-region bucket that
came out of that requirement.
Another example is the
customer said, OK, I
want to process this 100
petabytes in like 20 minutes.
And you do the math.
And it's like I need 20
terabits a second of throughput.
That's completely outrageous.
So I was able to work with the
security team and the customer
to back that down to
something reasonable.
So that's where the love-hate.
I mean, they love me when I'm
negotiating with the customer.
I'm basically
saving the platform.
But they hate me when I'm
demanding new features.
But this is ongoing.
I mean, any big
customer, it's exciting.
Right?
Product managers always want
to partner with the PSO people.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, but
those features sound amazing.
And it's so cool that they're
driven by real use cases
that we're running into and
solving problems for people
that are on our platform.
That's awesome.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Absolutely.
I mean, if you were
to tell me I could
have petabytes and petabytes
of data asynchronously copy
to two locations
at the same time,
I don't know how they do--
well, I do know how they do it.
MARK MANDEL: We have big pipes.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yeah.
It's pretty amazing.
AJA HAMMERLY: Very big
pipes and lots of magic.
[CHIMING]
ANN WALLACE: Our PMs,
they're super busy.
They are always very eager
to speak to the customers
and present to customers.
I'm in awe sometimes
how they get
everything done that they do.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Just to
add on, I mean, the platform
is changing so rapidly that,
literally, my full-time job
should just be monitoring
new beta features.
I tried to set up an RSS feed,
but that didn't really work.
I'm trying to figure
out a good way
to digest all this information.
So if any users out there have
a good method of doing this,
I'm all ears.
MARK MANDEL: I hear the podcast
is really good for that.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: But then
I'd be listening to podcasts,
like, 24 hours a day
ANN WALLACE: Well,
if you ran 30 miles,
you could listen to podcasts.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
we've heard about some
of the cool and challenging
problems you've run into.
Any others you want
to share with us?
Because I know
everyone loves hearing
about all the
other cool problems
that other people have.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: I'll even
speak for Ann on this one.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
Oh, no.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: You're getting
ready to roll to production.
You're ready to click the
button and just say go.
And then the CSO walks in
and says, what's going on?
And you're like, oh,
I'm migrating all
our infrastructure to Cloud.
And then he puts a
kibosh on the whole thing
because, obviously,
it hasn't gone
through the proper security
reviews, and audits,
and compliance.
And--
ANN WALLACE: I mean,
yeah, that's a true story.
And that's a true story
over and over again.
But I think now that we have
the security practice in some
of our sales teams, and our
technical account managers
know that they're trying to
get security at the table
to begin with, and
so we have unblocked
a couple of these
scenarios just by having
security folks in the room.
And regardless if
the security folks
were part of the
infrastructure team
two months ago, but because
they have that security title,
it's helped.
And again, it's just
trying to automate security
into the workflow to
begin with and having
it almost seamless, and so you
don't have to think about it.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, yeah,
you say automating security.
Are there any particular tools
or products that you've really
liked for doing
that kind of stuff?
ANN WALLACE: What
I like right now--
and I always end up
saying this incorrectly--
but for containers is using
Grafeas and Kritis for signing,
using that with
binary authorization.
So you can set policies to check
for multiple different things.
But for different
vulnerabilities,
vulnerability scores, if they're
high or medium or so forth,
and if those are
found, then Kritis
doesn't sign the
container image.
And if you go and try to
deploy it, it gets stopped.
So I think that's a
pretty neat tool that we
have out there right now.
So binary authorization is in
GCP and Grafeas and Kritis.
And again, I'm sorry if
I said that incorrectly.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
links in the show note.
We'll work it out.
ANN WALLACE: [LAUGHS]
Our open-source
projects that we have.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: You have
your technical issues.
And I think, probably
more importantly,
you have your people issues.
And it's generally the people
issues that kind of like
provide the roadblock.
And so in larger
migrations, you're
navigating emotions,
like I'm almost
a psychiatrist at
these projects.
I'm coaching them about
their cloud migration
and coaching them about
how to retrain their org.
And it's a lot of pressure.
You have to retrain people.
Maybe some people
might lose their jobs
as a result of some
of the migration.
So there's a lot of
people aspects to our job.
I've got a challenging one.
They've got an architecture
diagram from Miles Ward.
Miles Ward hands them
something beautiful.
It's amazing.
It's AI.
It's automated.
It's DR. Half the world
could get hit by a meteor,
and this thing would still run.
It's like they get handed
this, and they're like,
yes, I want it.
Then you go in there, and
they're running Windows 95.
Right?
So that can be challenging.
They know what they want.
They want the big picture and
the beautiful "Googliness."
And then it's just kind
of hard to get them there.
And so reality can
be tough sometimes.
But we're there to iterate
them and kind of help them out.
MARK MANDEL: So first
of all, hi, Miles.
Second of all, how do you
step people through that?
How do you take
someone from somewhere
where they're in a less
modern architecture
and bring them up to speed
in what may be cloud native
or whatever the
buzzword is right now?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: We're
working on a partner package,
a little package that
basically takes them
the first step to container.
So you can run a container
and orchestration
system like Kubernetes.
And it orchestrates
multiple containers,
and load balances, and it
does all that fun stuff.
But you can also run a container
in a one-to-one mapping
to a actual VM.
So I'm working on a
package that says, OK, I'm
going to take your VM.
I'm going to containerize
it, which gets you then
you can use the tools
that Ann mentioned
to kind of do the security
and get it in a registrar.
And then you're going to
deploy these containers
on a one-to-one mapping to GCE.
So now you're containerized,
but you're still
kind of running on a
lift-and-shift mode.
So that's a initial step.
And then security comes in,
and you get all the features.
Like GLB, for example, offers--
I believe it has DDoS and
other things like that.
Ann.
ANN WALLACE: Actually,
I have something
that's a little interesting.
I don't have an interesting
problem that we've solved.
But I think it's
something different
that PSO does and maybe other
cloud professional services
organizations.
And it just slipped
my mind because I've
been so focused on security.
But when I started at Google,
I was helping build out
CRE offerings with PSO.
So I think you've had
some of the CRE folks
on the podcast before.
So CRE, just for folks who
might not have heard that,
is Customer
Reliability Engineer.
So they are some of our
site reliability engineers
who are customer-facing and
work with some of our larger
customers on building out SRE
practices within their org.
So the CRE team is small
and just overbooked.
So they were looking to
see how they can grow this.
So they've partnered with PSO.
So we're starting to
offer CRE offerings.
So some of this is
just going in and doing
kind of basic SRE 101.
But then we also have
SLO-SLI workshops.
So this is taking a
customer's application,
and we're running
it through what
it might look like to set error
budgets and your SLO and SLIs.
So the little bit I got to work
on that six or so months ago
was really exciting.
But it's starting
to kick off now.
So there's a few folks within
PSO who are driving that.
So I'm really excited
to see where that goes.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Just
to follow up there,
I can't believe I forgot
the SRE portion of all this.
I partnered with Liz Fong-Jones,
one of my favorite people
on Earth.
ANN WALLACE: Yeah.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: It's
actually like a new construct.
So I came from another
large cloud vendor.
And we'd lift and shift,
and we'd lift and transform,
but we never talked
about operations.
And so, again, this is
coming with the whole,
I want to run like Google.
So you can lift and
shift a monolith
and actually apply
SRE principles
to these monolith applications.
So we're doing that as well.
So we're trying to kind of embed
this during the transition.
You know, it's just
a whole lot of fun
when you start talking
about error budgets
and how many nines.
The customer asked
for five nines,
but the application
they have is two nines.
It opens up for some
interesting conversations.
AJA HAMMERLY: So if people
want to get involved
with all this awesome
work you're doing in PSO,
where do they go?
MICHAEL WALLMAN: They
visit us at Google Next.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
ANN WALLACE: [LAUGHS]
MICHAEL WALLMAN:
Or, I believe, they
talk to their GCP counterparts,
the CE org, the sales team,
the technical account managers.
We're all tied together
like one Google.
So we're like a large hash map.
ANN WALLACE: cloud.google.com, I
think you can find us on there.
We have tons of job openings.
I think you could just
look for cloud consultant.
That will come up with things
in infrastructure, appdev,
security, ML.
MARK MANDEL: So it
sounds like if people
want to get in contact
with you, the best way
is through their account
rep or their sales contact.
ANN WALLACE: If they want to
get into contact with PSO, yeah.
I can tell you how to personally
get in contact with me.
But-- you know.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Yeah,
you can send me an email.
But I'm have thousands
and thousands
of emails unread at this point.
MARK MANDEL: Well, we
are running out of time,
unfortunately.
Is there anything you
both want to mention?
Are you doing anything
special for Next,
or something that you want to
make sure people know about,
anything along
those kind of lines
before we finish up today?
ANN WALLACE: Yeah,
I will be at Next.
I'm not speaking this year.
I am just going to be hanging
out, talking about security.
Right after, on April 13, is a
Woman Who Code CONNECT summit.
So I'll be speaking there.
That is also in San Francisco.
And the KubeCon EU speakers
just got announced.
So I'm going to be
speaking with Maya.
And we are going to be speaking
about Container Forensics, When
Your Cluster Becomes a Cluster.
MICHAEL WALLMAN:
That sounds cool.
Can I go?
Where is it?
ANN WALLACE: Barcelona.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I will be attending that.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
thank you so much to you
both for joining us
here on the podcast.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Thanks a lot.
ANN WALLACE: Thanks
for having us.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: Bye.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so
much to Ann and Michael
coming to hang out with us.
It's always really
interesting to hear
about teams internal to Google,
how they help customers,
and how they help support them--
so super happy to have them on.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah,
that was a great chance
to talk and learn about
something that I didn't
actually know much about yet.
But now it is time for
question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And our question this week
has to do with Cloud Build.
And the question is, how do
you cache files between builds
in Cloud Build, which is
something that a lot of folks
want to do to speed
up their builds and/or
because they've got interesting
pipelines that they're
trying to build where they have
lots of different dependencies.
So, Mark, what is the
answer to this question?
MARK MANDEL: I had
exactly this problem.
Basically, I had
a file-based case
that I wanted to store
some records in and just
persist it between builds
to make things a bit faster.
And I was like, OK, clearly,
I have Google Cloud Storage.
I can push stuff up and down.
But what if it's not there?
What if it is?
I don't want to
write all this code.
So I went hunting
through the repository,
which is the Cloud
Builders Community
Repository under Google
Cloud Platform, which
has a bunch of Google
Cloud Builder steps.
Now, these are
custom-build steps
that you can use yourself
inside Cloud Build that
do some kind of fancy things.
And there's a whole
bunch of them.
I'm not going to go
through them all.
But one of them that stands
out and one that I really like
is there is a cache
build step, or a cache,
depending on whether you're
Australian or American.
And what it has, it has a
safe cache and a restore cache
functionality.
So it will take basically
any path that you like
and check it in
Google Cloud Storage.
You can have keys.
You can have your
own keys if you want.
You can tell it what bucket
you want to put into.
It will even do checksumming
of a particular file.
So if you want the
cache to be stored
within the checksum
of a file and you
want it to change
when the file change,
it's all kind of baked
in and just works.
So if you're looking
for that, we'll
put a link in the show notes.
But it's super handy.
I just put it in.
It just worked.
It was great.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
And that whole community,
all those community
supply builders are really
great because, oftentimes,
the problems we have are
problems someone else
has already solved.
And we're really grateful to
the community for the ones
that they've contributed.
So even if caching
isn't your problem,
you should totally go check
out Community Builders
Repository on GitHub and see
what other folks have built.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, before we wrap up,
Aja, what are you doing?
Where are you going?
Doing anything cool?
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm not
doing anything cool.
I am taking a break
from travel and events
to focus on family,
and my career,
and a bunch of other
really boring stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Good for you.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm
going to be online.
If people want to
see what I'm up to,
they can totally check out
my blog at thagomizer.com.
Or they can follow
me on Twitter.
I am the_thagomizer.
And for those who don't
know, a thagomizer
is the spiky part at the
end of a Stegosaurus.
I've got blog posts
that are written
and going to be released
in the next couple of weeks
on doing coding
assessments in interviews--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: --what we can
do instead of whiteboards
because there's been a bunch
of tweets recently about
whiteboards being awful.
And then I have a
horrible project idea
that I'm going to use with Ruby,
and GCP, and cloud storage,
and probably some of
the ML APIs that I
hope to have blog post about
in the next couple of weeks
that folks can check
out, especially
all of my Ruby friends.
And a new version
of Ruby was just
released at Ruby [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm going to check out
pattern matching has been
outed as a potential feature.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
AJA HAMMERLY: And I'm
going to check that out
because I love me
some pattern matching.
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
AJA HAMMERLY: So if you're
curious about my thoughts
on any of those things,
follow me online.
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
AJA HAMMERLY: How
about you, Mark?
Where are you going to go?
And what are you
going to be up to?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So in, what, two or three
weeks, I will be at Google I/O.
I'll be doing the
presentation there
about open match in
Agones, working together,
games on top of Kubernetes in
open source, unsurprisingly.
I'll mention something
that's a little bit further
in the future as well.
In August, there is an
Open Source in Gaming Day.
So people may be familiar with
the Open Source North America
Summit under the
Linux Foundation.
And we've been working with
them and some other people
looking to advocate
for more open source
in the games industry.
So we're going to have a day.
It's August 20.
It's co-located with the events.
So it's going to
be the day before.
So if you are
interested in attending,
we'll have details
in the show notes.
But if you have any
particular open-source stories
around anything pretty
much to do with gaming,
there is a call for papers
open as well until May 4.
I believe that date's correct.
I will also have the link
in the show notes as well.
So that'll be fun.
That's coming up in August.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, Aja, I think
that wraps things up.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
So thank you all for listening.
We'll have another awesome
episode for you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]